bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoints
dans fit l'écho dans ce magazine nous
allons parler sport en entreprise effet
anti stress cohésion des équipes les
bienfaits des activités sportives sont
multiples et les sociétés vont bien
compris nous irons à la rencontre d'un
coach sportif qui intervient en
entreprise et nous suivons trois
collègues de travail qui participent à
un raid interentreprises les avant cela
je vous propose de découvrir des
infrastructures sportives dédiées à des
salariés d'un grand groupe yvelinois le
sporting brigue suivez-moi
[Musique]
situé à guyancourt à deux pas de
challenger le siège de bouygues ses
infrastructures sportives s'étendent sur
3 ha nous voici au sporting wings
étaient amarrés vous êtes le responsable
sport de boules construction commence à
fonctionner ce que c'est ouvert à tous
les salariés de wing et ce qu'il peut
venir quand ils le souhaitent alors oui
tout à fait c'est ouvert à tous les
salariés du groupe bouygues ils peuvent
venir entre 12 heures et 14 heures et le
soir de 17 heures à 22 heures 30 une
pause déjeuner et puis après le travail
faisait je n'ai et après le travail
alors quel sport on peut pratiquer ou
alors on a vingt sections ici sur le
sporting ça va du tennis puisque on a
neuf courts de tennis couverts en
passant par le foot en passant par le
yoga par la salsa aussi et on a
également une grosse section rugby et
golf les gens peuvent finalement venir
pour venir faire du sport indépendamment
également suivre des cours oui il ya
dans chaque discipline on essaye d'avoir
des intervenants donc des coachs ou des
profs donc il ya pour le loisir mais où
il ya aussi pour toutes nos sections
corpo qui font de la compétition que ce
soit donc en détente au lourd en
compétition qu'est ce que le sport peut
apporter aux salariés ferment mais moi
je pense que le sport évidemment c'est
significatif de bien-être donc
évidemment du bien-être mais ce qui se
passe surtout sur le sporting sait que
le sporting est un outil social pour
l'entreprise et se retrouve ici en fait
tous les collaborateurs il ya plus de
niveaux de hiérarchie voyez on est entre
directeurs entre employés et tout ça se
mélange autour d'une vraie passion ma
leur passion qu'est le sport
d'ailleurs tous les midis des salariés
viennent sur leur pause déjeuner pour
avoir une vraie coupure avec le travail
actuellement le squash que je trouve ça
très bien parce qu'on a besoin de temps
très très court on arrive à en évacuer
parce que c'est encore asséné assez
intensif et puis ça me permets moi de
rendre sur une un break complète
médicaux aux infrastructures font des
envieux d'autres entreprises vous ont
contacté pour avoir accès finalement
intéressé salle voilà alors nous on sait
on s'est engagé auprès de certaines
sociétés on est donc on a des
infrastructures qui sont grandes on a
encore la possibilité de prendre des
sociétés dont nos par où on s'est dit
que dans les sections ça serait bien
d'avoir 30 % d'extérieur bien sûr ne pas
en avoir plus mais 30% dits extérieurs
les sociétés qui l'aurait de la
communauté d'agglomération voilà je
pense que ça serait raisonnable et
encore et qui encore de la place pour
ces sociétés
vous avez combien d'adhérents
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui nous avons alors
mille huit cents adhérents sachant que
800 adhérents sont dans notre salle de
fitness et que les autres sont inscrits
six dans les vingt sections en plus du
sporting il propose effectivement une
salle de fitness et de musculation de
600 mètres carrés exclusivement pour ses
salariés dans les locaux de challenger
son siège il va y avoir encore des
évolutions l'inde évolution et une salle
de futsal va être créé bientôt oui tout
à fait urban football donc avec lequel
on est en partenariat au sein plantes
sur notre site donc évidemment on aura
des heures pour nos collaborateurs et
tous ceux qui ont rejoint la sm il y
aura des heures qui sont attribués à
nous les ja le salarié voilà c'est ça
vous parliez de beaucoup d'évolution
vous avez une autre idée on a encore
beaucoup de choses on travaille beaucoup
sur le handicap nous ce qu'on aimerait
faire de ce site comme vous le voyez en
matinée et en après-midi devenir un
centre
handisport en 10 tennis je pense surtout
au tennis puisqu'aujourd'hui il ya très
peu de structures qui accueillent des
handicapés et celle ci serait serait
parfaite stéphane marais merci merci
nous allons maintenant retrouver trois
salariés du groupe la poste et des
collègues de travail qui se sont lancés
dans une aventure sportive un raid
interentreprises siham chantal et
antonin se prépare pour une course
sportive pas comme les autres le trophée
des entreprises ici les équipes sont
formées de collègues de travail et porte
les couleurs de leur société pour les
trois compétiteurs des maillots jaunes
car tout ce travail à la plateforme
industrielle courrier de bois d'arcy la
pique mais aujourd'hui ils sont un peu
plus que le simple collègue le sport et
l'esprit d'équipé des as de la pique
comme ils se sont appelés prennent le
pas sur la hiérarchie j'aurais paraît
simple stagiaire on est une équipe et on
est tous au même niveau en fait est
difficile sorti depuis quelques semaines
les trois collègues s'entraînent
ensemble à la course principalement mais
d'autres épreuves les attendent et siham
compte sur la complémentarité de
l'équipe
tous les fronts on est complètement vide
en moi c'est tout à la présentation naim
c'est plutôt le vtt mais non c'est
plutôt qu'à nourrir
donc la jirs est le seul sport où on
n'est pas trop à l'aise c'est la course
à pied mais bon chacun un kilomètre ça
devrait aller kitty compétition festive
des échauffements festif c'est en muse
se prépare aux épreuves
[Musique]
les as de l'apix se prennent vite au jeu
à quelques minutes du début de la course
no stress
permanent on comptait encore du travail
a continué
après l'échauffement l'équipe retrouve
d'autres collègues venus participer au
raid en tout le groupe la poste compte
10 équipes sur cette compétition antonin
6-1 et chantal sont partis pour près de
sept kilomètres de course
[Applaudissements]
les as de l'apic finiront 62e sur 63
mais l'important était de participer
la course at elle vraiment changer
quelque chose dans leur relation pour le
savoir changement de décor nous
retrouvons les trois compétiteurs sur
leur lieu de travail
justiciables à 100 sa communication de
la plateforme industrielle courrier de
bois d'arcy et comme vous pouvez le voir
dans la vie de tous les jours je ne
porte pas jogging voilà donc je suis
habillé pour mon travail alors moi ces
chantages suis technicien qualité sur la
pique de bois d'arcy je m'appelle
antonin je suis actuellement en stage à
la pique de bois d'arcy j'ai troqué mon
maillot jaune pour mon gilet noir de la
poste avec quelques stages à son actif
antonin découvre le monde du travail
participer à des événements sportifs
entre collègues est une nouveauté pour
lui est un moyen de mieux s'intégrer
dans la société on reparle de
l'événement bas des difficultés qu'on a
rencontrés ou encore bas c'est vrai que
maintenant on en rigole du coût de ces
difficultés donc c'est sympa aussi et
c'est vrai que ça craybas une cohésion
de groupe que je bats que je connaissais
pas vu que ça faisait pas longtemps que
que j'étais dans l'entreprise donc c'est
vrai que ça tisser quelques liens
antonin et le petit nouveau mais siam et
chantal se connaissent depuis trois ans
à la base simples collègues elles se
sont rapprochées il ya un an en
participant ensemble à la parisienne 6
km de course en portant les couleurs de
leur société depuis elle ne s'arrête
plus ces sorties du cas du travail
certaines font des entraînements
ensemble
et danser si on va ensemble c'est le
soir après le boulot donc on s'éclate
aussi même aux entraînements le sport un
moyen de créer du lien social et de
renforcer le bien-être au bureau des
notions de plus en plus recherchée par
les salariés pour qui travaille doit
rimer avec plaisir quand j'ai change
avec mes collègues responsable
communication autre plateforme au niveau
national on voit quand même que y'a
vraiment plus de deux projets autour du
sport du bien-être de massage la
nutrition la participation des salariés
à des courses comme la parisienne où le
trophée des entreprises fait partie de
la politique sociétal du groupe la poste
pour en savoir plus nous allons faire un
point avec la directrice courrier des
yvelines
hocevar bonjour bonjour la poste se
positionne comme une entreprise qui
aiment le sport pour reprendre un de vos
slogans qu'est-ce qu'ils ont mis en
place concrètement pour les salariés
alors pour les salariés ont la première
manifestation très visible qui a été
mise en place et la participation des
équipes au trophée saint quentin en
yvelines avec une troisième édition
cette année ça avait commencé en 2011
avec les équipes qui s'étaient
constituées de manière spontanée donc la
poste avait accompagné le financement
des inscriptions puis ça a été
renouvelée en 2012 et donc en 2013 on a
décidé de travailler avec les salariés
de la poste pour rendre cette
participation beaucoup plus visible au
niveau de l'entreprise la poste quel est
l'intérêt pour vos salariés alors pour
les salariés c'est c'est la traduction
vraiment
au quotidien des valeurs de l'entreprise
la proximité l'entr'aide l'esprit
d'équipé c'est aussi travailler sur la
performance et de bien-être des salariés
dans l'entreprise parce que sur les
aigus m'engager sur un plan d'action du
scion qui c'est votre performance et
bien-être ou en cherche à valoriser les
actions un peu en marche de l'entreprise
qui garantissent que nous avions se
sentent bien au travail merci beaucoup
nous voici maintenant acquis tenace
academy chaque année on y forme
plusieurs centaines de tous ces sportifs
une fois diplômés certains restent dans
cette société pour pouvoir donner des
cours à des particuliers comme dans ce
centre ici à mon père mais aussi aux
entreprises dans les yvelines rencontre
parmi leurs clients et eads wing ou
encore malakoff médéric
[Musique]
arnaud sierre bonjour vous êtes le
directeur de fitness academy vous venez
donc de lafitte les éditions payantes du
monde de cette discipline en 1999
comment vous est venu finalement l'idée
d'intégrer le fitness dans le monde de
l'entreprise on est bien en fait c'est
parce que j'ai monté une école de
formation qui s'appelle t pince academy
au début on ne faisait que de la
formation et puis en fait mes élèves ont
une particularité c'est que je suis très
exigeant avec eux aussi bien sur le
savoir faire que sur le savoir être et
cette prestation de mélange savoir faire
savoir être est très prisée en
entreprise donc il ya beaucoup de
directeurs de sociétés qui m'ont
contacté pour cela au début je le
faisais à côté de la formation et puis
maintenant c'est devenu seulement une
activité principale chez nous on fait
autant d'informations que deux
placements de coach en entreprise
injustement il ya de plus en plus de
demande du coach sportif dans les
entreprises pourquoi cet engouement
vient en fait la crise ne nous fait pas
mal du tout nouveau monde du fitness je
pense que les gens dans une société sont
particulièrement stressés en ce moment
ils ont besoin justement de se vider un
petit peu la tête de se faire du bien
encore et j'ai de plus en plus de
contacts de directeur de société pour
cela pour déstresser leurs salariés pour
faire qui lui passe un bon moment en
entreprise ça développe le présentiel
donc sont plus présents plus motivés à
travailler et ils viennent bien sûr pour
travailler évidemment mais aussi leurs
petites heures de ce corps le midi
compte beaucoup dans leur culte en
dessous des entreprises n'ont pas
forcément les structures adaptées
comment vous adaptez alors fait on
s'adapte à toutes situations il ya des
salles qui ont vraiment une énorme
structure dans leurs locaux parce qu'ils
ont énormément de salariés donc quand on
est passé trois quatre cinq mille
employés on a une salle de fitness digne
de ce nom avec des machines et des
salles de cours mais on peut
d'intervenir on est vraiment toute
petite société aux alentours de 50 cents
salariés où il suffit de réquisitionner
une salle de formation on déplace un
petit peu les tables pour faire des
cours de sophrologie de yoga de pilates
même des cours de renforcement
musculaire ce qu'ils font est ce qui
fait énormément de bien aux salariés sur
l'heure du midi vous vivez vous êtes
aussi centre de formation vous recruter
parmi nouveaux élèves mais finalement
les coachs sportifs qui auront en
entreprise par la suite alors pourquoi
est ce qu'ils aient une formation
spécifique corporate où est la raison
est toute autre en corporate c'est
vraiment être un état d'esprit différent
c'est principalement faire du bien aux
salariés donc ils se détendent et qu'il
passe un bon moment ensemble donc on
n'est pas dans l'esprit parfois qui
règne dans les salles de fitness et sans
esprit un peu encore m'as tu vu parfois
donc là c'est vraiment surtout le
principal c'est en corporate on se fait
du bien et on passe un bon moment
ensemble
combien d'entreprises vous intervenez
notamment dans les yvelines alors en
tournant n'ont maintenant plus d'une
quinzaine de sociétés donc sur paris sur
le 92 elle 78 principalement et
particulièrement dans 70 des cas
actuellement les présents sur six
dernière question prochainement je pense
que vous comptez vous élargir reposer
d'autres activités que le fitness aux
entreprises oui effectivement maintenant
et société noces une sollicite également
pour des choses qui sont un petit peu d
à côté du fitness comme le coaching
mental ou tout ce qui est massage ou
prestations en méditation yoga donc ce
sont les principaux axes de
développement d'ici à l'année prochaine
ça va encore durer cent
vu pas mal
merci merci
c'est la fin de ce fil échos le dernier
la saison merci de nous avoir suivis à
la rentrée de septembre vous retrouverez
ce magazine sous une autre formule tous
les jeudis soirs
[Musique]